there is a very famous guy who is
admitting
to another kind of sex addiction porn
addiction
terry crews is opening up about his porn
addiction and how it almost
destroyed his marriage it was like wait
a minute like
i actually just need to be a better
person for myself
and and he basically said whether i
can't promise you whether your wife
was ever going to come back to you you
may have lost her forever
but you still need to get better for
yourself
however this is crazy you're right
because this is another thing success is
the warmest place to hide
i had so many people that were telling
me i was great
that it was no problem that you're doing
this and you know what hollywood didn't
care
it still doesn't care if you lose your
family it happens every day
they're like hey man but now you can put
you in three movies and i wanted to add
that this addiction preceded the
marriage
so fame just made it worse and it's
really true that
that power that success amplifies what's
already going on inside you
and that is why i couldn't help him and
i'm thankful and i'm lucky
that he made the choice to do that this
porn addiction thing is a big problem i
cannot tell you
how many letters i get into the mailbag
and people sending in tweets and things
like that
who are young men who are asking about
porn addiction who are in despair
because they got hooked on porn from
when they were eight years old or
something
i mean i think that the average age that
boys are exposed to porn is like
10 or 11 and because it was when they
were so young it totally warped their
minds and they got stuck and it screws
up their relationship and it screws up
their sense of self-worth and screws up
their sense of the world
and this issue is one that is not really
talked about
and when it is talked about it's talked
about with flippancy
and glibness and the stale rhetoric of
the left and the right for that matter
on the right which you hear from the
kind of
basic boomer libertarian conservative
rhetoric is
yeah come on you can't ban porn it's
free speech come on
you don't want to ban porn first first
of all you hear it from the
right wingers who they just really want
to be cool you know like i'm not an
i'm not i'm not a usual kind of right
winger i'm a cool
right winger it's like the mother and
mean girls you know i'm not a regular
mom i'm a cool i'm a cool conservative
you know yeah i like porn or whatever
and so you you hear that kind of
silliness which there's nothing
conservative about
porn okay but also porn has not
protected free speech it's just not it
never has been
and it probably it may very well be but
only because people are conflating
liberty and licentiousness
obscenity has never been protected by
law okay going back to the
earliest days of our of our country
actually
even before the country was officially
founded you know in in the late 18th
century
going back to governor bradford okay
going back to the mayflower and plymouth
colony
there was a guy from a nearby colony who
wrote what what governor bradford
considered to be sort of
lecherous sonnets you know little little
poems that he felt were a little too
titillating for puritanical austerity
and governor bradford very nearly
executed him for that
okay and ultimately he said uh it'll be
kind of bad for the diplomatic issues
here
so instead governor bradford in his
great mercy marooned him on an island
until a ship from england could take him
back
and get him out of the mother country
okay that tradition goes back very far
in america and in the early days we had
protections against obscenity and we
were still enforcing them
as recently as 2009 2009
at the tail end of the bush
administration there was a pornographer
who was sent to prison
for obscenity charges not even it's not
even like it was child porn or it was
this it was just
for obscene stuff we have lots of
limitations on this
we always have until recently when
conservatives putative conservatives
bought the liberal stupid rhetoric
about how there's nothing more american
and nothing more protected by the first
amendment
than looking at ladies jiggle on the
internet or
weirder stuff you know there's basically
a porn for everything right that's
the expression goes if you can think it
there's a porn for it that stuff we've
got to take that seriously so you got to
ditch this stupid
right-wing rhetoric on it and you got to
ditch the stupid left-wing rhetoric on
it that it's this is somehow good for
you i mean the left has been pushing the
sexualization of children
for decades and decades and decades it
goes back at least to one of these kooky
left theorists wilhelm reich who was
writing a century ago almost a century
ago
and and then you see the same nonsense
espoused by bernie sanders himself
very prominent left winger almost got
the democratic nomination for president
he's been a senator for forever
and he would write essays in the 60s in
the vermont freeman
about how we need to sexualize children
and how that's good for them
now we we need to normalize these sorts
of things you can read about that by the
way in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
for pre-order the left has been pushing
that we got to ditch that kind of crazy
writer and by the way you want to talk
about stale rhetoric
the left always says that young men
toxic young men they need to talk about
their feelings and their problems
well okay the ones who are writing into
my show talking about this
very real issue they're talking about
their feelings and their problems and
what happens
they get made fun of they get called in
cells they get called losers they get
called basement dwellers by by the very
libs
who are saying that the young men need
to talk about their feelings but we are
not
we are not allowed to
to talk about that because of this it's
it's not even because we don't
understand that there is an issue i
think people do sense that there's an
issue on the left and the right
but we're just locked in this prism of
stupid stupid
slogans and it's it's being enforced by
the liberal establishment
hey hey you you got to ring the bell
they don't like it they don't like it
here at youtube when you ring the bell
and you get notifications
but do it do it anyway before they shut
us down ring the bell
subscribe like it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you